I was always better at math and science
in high school so I figured I would do
something in tech that was lucrative I
went to UC Berkeley and major in
electrical engineering computer science
I know it's a mouthful I think a lot of
college students enter a practical major
and tell themselves oh I don't really
like my classes are my classmates but
once I get into a big company like
Google or Facebook with free massages
free food and a six-figure salary I'll
be happy it'll all be worth it that was
me I eventually got what I wanted I got
an amazing internship pay was high I had
free food every day I had the massages
but I came to a very scary realization
even with all the perks and money you
still have to go back to the work I
thought something was wrong with me am I
just being a spoiled brat is this just
how the world works it took me that
summer to make peace with the idea that
I didn't want this anymore
maybe I never did I think I realized
then that being honest with yourself is
a lot harder than it sounds thanks to my
internships joining a theater club and
seeing successful youtubers like Natalie
trans superwoman and Wong foo I decided
I wanted to go into content creation but
it was too late for me to switch majors
so I decided to just graduate as an
engineer I didn't have any sense of
accomplishment when I want to get my
diploma I actually fought with my mom
right before the ceremony why can't you
just make this a hobby why are you doing
this to me why can't you just make a lot
of money for ten years and then do what
you want I don't see any Asians in
Hollywood so you have a one percent
chance of succeeding that fight still
hurts when I think about it I felt so
unseen and misunderstood but I can't
blame her for saying those things and
now I'm here and I feel beyond
privileged that I proved her wrong and
have a salary for doing exactly what I
want to do we're okay now but I know
that there are plenty of kids out there
with parents who push them in a
direction that's more comfortable
or practical if you're listening I hope
you realize that you're not alone as
much as we love and respect our
Guardians they don't always know what's
best for us your life is your own and
you deserve to eventually look back at
your life knowing you lived it the way
you wanted to
I feel more driven and fulfilled than I
ever could be as a programmer now that
I'm living my life so truthfully who is
by no means easy to get here but I have
faith that you can do it too
[Music]